hey guys it's Kayla back with another
video so the topic of today's video is
being yourself being yourself can be
hard and it's like aren't I always being
myself and yeah for sure
but being yourself is like not changing
yourself to impress someone else a lot
of people I call me quiet or shy or
whatever
but I'm not quiet most quiet Kayla day I
don't talk a lot at school but if people
talk to me and stuff they'd find out
that I'm like really funny and cool and
talking by the way I like your shirt a
lot it's like so cool
[Music]
I said one more week of eighth-grade
right yeah that's crazy yeah uh-huh
okay so growing up can be a little bit
scary and weird we will begin to explore
these changing bodies of yours it's
gonna be men always make sure to share
it and subscribe to my channel duty I
think you're so cool
maybe you just need to put yourself out
there a little I'm gonna stop you say
one thing really like nervous over time
they try really hard not to feel that
way but you just need to face your fears
[Music]
black people know they're really
[Music]
just grab my phone how to charge it yeah
I mean he sometimes I charged it you but
my my phone I
just because things are happening right
now doesn't mean they're always cannot
happen
who's in there just sort of my hopes and
dreams right I was a complete bathroom
when I was your age
really eighth grade is go work you never
know what's next and that's what makes
things exciting scary
and fun when did you get snapshot we're
good
Fisk Ramos is great
[Music]